hi guys alright so I wanted to talk
about one of my favorite features on the
phone and that's the GPS now this is
amazing because there's a ton of
different applications that use the GPS
and you can use it to find your friends
they can find you you guys can pick a
place to meet or you can even stalk them
but what if you don't want to be stalked
well it's really easy all you have to do
is disable the GPS you go into the
settings like so and click general and
click the location services off and
that's it you're completely off the grid
and even Big Brother can't find you haha
seize her go to take 180 comm slash
iJustine to see what happens next let's
put on a show